curious to know which home improvement
guest star was also in back to the
future and did you know that one of the
show's recurring characters co-founded
the la improv troupe the groundlings
keep watching to find out more
when tim and his family sought advice or
needed to vent they often went into
their backyard and talked things over
with their plane spoken neighbor wilson
w wilson played by earl hindman the
character was based on tim allen's
childhood neighbor whose face was hidden
because alan was too short to see him
completely wilson was forever obscured
by a fence and a hat which was the
show's long-running gag that grew even
more complicated and humorous as it let
him out of the house and into the world
more often after appearing in almost
every episode wilson's face was finally
revealed to the audience in the series
finale curtain call heinzmann's face
started to get recognized back in the
70s with supporting roles in films like
the parallax view and the taking of
pelham 1-2-3 outside of home improvement
his most well-known role was detective
bob reed on the soap opera ryan's hope
fittingly his final contribution to
television was lending his voice as a
narrator of the tim allen presents a
user's guide to home improvement
retrospective from 2003. that same year
hindman died of lung cancer at the age
of 61. in early 2021 tim allen paid
tribute to wilson on his other hit
sitcom last man standing where his newer
character mike baxter meets his older
one tim taylor oh he's found it easier
to open up and i'm just talking to the
top half of another man's face
in a kill or be killed type profession
drummer turned actor mickey jones
estimated in 2009 that he had killed 137
people and had been killed 92 times on
screens big and small that is in one of
his numerous roles he was killing it in
a humorous sort of way on home
improvement he played kmb construction
worker pete bilker for 13 episodes pete
rocked out with tim and the tour time
gang cooking and drinking up a storm in
honor of st patrick and the super bowl
and playing in a band using tools as
instruments let's roll
b
that would be me
you once even watched him fall into a
porter john on a job site talk about
your body humor jones entertainment
business journey began on the music side
as a drummer for trini lopez then for
johnny rivers where he provided the
backing beat to the hit a secret agent
man next he replaced lee von helm behind
the kit and toured with bob dylan on his
landmark 1966 world tour jones was also
a founding member of the rock group the
first edition with kenny rogers an
apparent forest gump of the
entertainment industry for multiple
decades he seemed to be everywhere
including an appearance in the gatefold
photo standing behind the eagles inside
the hotel california lp in speaking
about his change of mediums jones had
this to say i had always dreamed of
being an actor so i went for it he went
on to find roles as bearded tough guys
bikers and nice bearded guys who
sometimes ride bikes and flicks like
national lampoon's vacation and
slingblade later on in his career jones
appeared as a series regular on the fx
crime drama justified he died at the age
of 76 in 2018.
tim's buddy harry owned a hardware store
where mr tool time liked to enjoy his
time off however it's not usually fun
when harry's wife dolores is around to
bust his chops argue with him over
everything and give him the look dolores
was played by comedian shirley prestia
and the role ended up being one of the
biggest of her career a memorable
episode finds her working at the store
and driving everyone insane this leads
to tim giving harry bad advice that in
turn nearly dissolves his marriage
however tim realizes he's done wrong so
he works to fix that making the title of
the episode ring true when harry kept
dolores prestia was one of the founding
members of the los angeles-based improv
and sketch comedy team the groundlings
in the 1970s it was during her time at
the groundlings that she yucked it up on
stage alongside legends such as paul
rubins phil hartman and lorraine newman
she went on to a steady career of guest
starring and bit parts and sitcoms such
as cheers and films like wag the dog
after an eight-year battle with brain
cancer prestia died in 2011 at the age
of 64.
the titular yi old shop teacher that
inspired a young timothy taylor to a
life of more power pays his prized pupil
a visit three times in consecutive
seasons portrayed by dick o'neill our
leonard first arrives at a shell of his
former self who is unable to operate
heavy machinery due to his arthritis
next in the episode titled that's my
mama he made wanted advances on tim's
mom which were unwanted by the sun
things got even stranger when tim caught
mr leonard shopping around with another
woman the tall man then confronted his
teacher about it saying
but all ended well with some kissing and
making up straight talking men of
authority with a tinge of a smile were
the types of characters o'neil excelled
at playing he served the public
portraying fictional policemen
detectives army personnel commissioners
wardens and judges in a wide range of
shows like barney miller different
strokes and family matters additionally
o'neill played sharon lester's pops on
26 episodes of cagney and lacey never
usually the star he supported others as
well as he did with carnival barker
steve martin and the jerk jack nicholson
in pritzy's honor and harrison ford in
the mosquito coast he even tangled with
earl hindman before in the taking of
pelham 123 as subway dispatcher franco
coral o'neill died of heart failure in
1998 at the age of 70.
master plumber felix meiman was a key
figure for six episodes of home
improvement showing up at the taylor
household for all of the family's
plumbing disasters he once even gotten
the crossfire of a culkin gun battle
between tim and al on tour time felix
was played by al fan a productive actor
and student of theater who even founded
his own namesake theatrical ensemble to
train and develop aspiring young stage
actors fans professional breakthrough
came in 1953 on the bob hope network
television show and wrapped up in the
coen brothers 2004 remake of the lady
killers in between he popped up in good
times the jeffersons happy days and curb
your enthusiasm alfan passed away in
2018 at the age of 93.
tom poston is perhaps one of the most
prolific comedic actors to appear on tv
sitcoms so it's no shock that his resume
included ratcheting it up on home
improvement three different times he
first showed up as a multi-hibernated
desk clerk named fred trying to help her
snowden tim and al get home in toss the
night before christmas the next season
he played fred's brother ned a helpful
auto shop owner who allows it to become
a delivery room and the tall man
delivers fred and ned's brother ted is
the tailor's personal guide at the
annual detroit lions thanksgiving day
game although this time around it's tim
who is of no help as he knocks out the
stadium's electricity steve allen done
nuts bob newhart tim conway these are
among the revered comedy legends i
worked with and greatly respected poston
however he may not be as appreciated as
many of his contemporaries were his
career thrived on supporting work and
his television resume read like a what's
worse of sitcom history with roles and
get smart new hearts murphy brown and
will and grace well not a giant film
actor he did make some appearances on
the big screen including spending
another christmas time with tim allen in
2004's christmas with the cranks poston
passed on in 2007 at the age of 85.
and morgan gilbert was only 14 years
older than earl hindman when she showed
up to play the woman who brought wilson
jr into the world for the mother's day
themed episode to build or not to build
sure it's good to meet you
i see where wilson gets his good looks
wilson flew in from the yukon and the
two were excited to celebrate in greek
town but before they headed out they
imparted wisdom and motherly gift ideas
to tim on behalf of his boys a d grade
in chemistry at stamford led this
nursing student to switch majors to
speech and drama which subsequently
launched gilbert's long-acting career
her first big role was playing neighbor
millie helper on the dick van dyke show
she also played nora for 10 episodes on
the new andy griffith show talked fresh
produce with burgess meredith and
grumpier old men and guest starred on
both seinfeld and curb your enthusiasm
gilbert also portrayed a grandmother on
the nanny and in the 2010 film please
give she acted up until 2016 when she
died of cancer at age 87. a mother
herself she is survived by two daughters
including actress haley todd who played
the mother on lizzie mcguire as the
clock started to run out on home
improvement things got a bit corrosive
and explosive in the show's three-part
finale the long and winding road in the
episode a new producer of tall time
wants to spice things up by putting the
tools down and doing a talk only program
but what he actually does is stage a
jerry springer-like three-ring circus
during the segment a character named sue
claims she has been cheating on her
husband which leads to an onset brawl
brassy mouth sue played with high
intensity by wendy joe berber came out
swinging and ended up kicking tim in the
chin the rating stunt left him furious
and questioning whether to go on with
the show sperber broke into hollywood as
a scene stealer right off the bat in
robert zemeckis's 1978 beatlemania pick
i want to hold your hand she would
re-team with zemeckis and join steven
spielberg for 1941 and the first and
third installments of back to the future
where she notably played marty mcfly's
disinterested sister linda sperber also
collaborated with tom hanks on the tv
show bosom buddies and joined him again
two years later in bachelor party sadly
she died of breast cancer in 2005 at the
age of 47.